our second talk um
of the day we are happy to have uh colin
mcswiggen
from nyu telling us about sampling
matrices from hci z distributions
all right uh thanks a lot to the
organizers for inviting me to present at
this workshop
everything that i'm going to talk about
today is joint work with nasheed fishnoi
and also with jonathan leake who gave
the previous talk
i'm going to
talk about a couple of new algorithms
for sampling matrices from harish
chandra isix and zubair or hci z
distributions
these are distributions with exponential
densities on orbits of the unitary group
as it acts on the space of n by n
hermitian matrices and these sampling
algorithms have
applications
to differential privacy quantum
information statistics and we'll talk
about a couple of these applications at
the beginning as a way of motivating the
main results that i'll show you later
so the first motivating example is to
something called differential privacy
so for some background uh imagine the
following situation you are some
institution like the census bureau or
netflix
and you want to release some data set
disclose it to the public
so if you're the census bureau maybe you
want to release census data so that it
can be analyzed by economists or
sociologists if you're netflix maybe you
want to release a bunch of user data so
that it can be used in the netflix
challenge so that independent
researchers can help you to design a
better recommendation system
the problem is that this data concerns
some population of individuals and the
data related to individuals is private
it's confidential
so netflix found this out the hard way
it turns out that people really don't
like it when you publish a list of all
the tv shows they've been watching
they
were sued over this and they had to
cancel the second netflix challenge
and the irony is that they had actually
tried to anonymize their data but we
know very well by now that ad hoc
anonymization schemes are extremely
prone to failure it's just very hard to
anonymize
data successfully in an ad hoc way
so what you need if you are going to try
to release a big data set that's
important that remain anonymized is some
kind of provable privacy guarantee
so here's
some intuition for how a system that
provides that might work
instead of releasing the data directly
you could release a random permutation
of the data such that changes to the
information of a single individual are
hard to detect
that is you want to use the randomness
to guarantee that the probability of any
event that depends on the output data
can only vary negligibly
as a function of data associated to any
individual and as a consequence it's
difficult for someone observing that
output to infer what the data associated
to an individual was
so
that's sort of how the the intuition for
how such system might work uh here's a
formal definition
a randomized function f
is called epsilon differentially private
if for all input data sets d1 and d2
which differ only on a single user in a
sense to be defined and for all s in the
range of the function
the probability of the event that the
function applied to d1 lies in the set s
is at most equal to e to the power
epsilon times the probability that f of
d2 lies in that same set now note that
because this has to hold for all input
data sets this inequality is reversible
so all that this tells us is that the
probability of these two events can't be
too different
now
the formal meaning of this phrase
differing on a single user is going to
depend on the application
for all of the cases that i'll talk
about in this talk the input data sets
d1 and d2 will be matrices and by
differing on a single user we simply
mean that the spectral norm of the
difference of those matrices is at most
one
now
why would you want to use this
definition well it turns out to have
some really good properties
so for example uh differential privacy
defined in this way is robust under
repeated application so if i have some
epsilon differentially private function
and i apply it k times to different data
sets that might overlap
and i show you the output of all of
those data sets that combined function
is still k times epsilon differentially
private likewise it's robust under post
processing so if i input the output of a
differentially private function into
another function and tell you the output
of that function that's still epsilon
differentially right
all right so how can we implement a
differentially private function in
practice well
we want to output something that's close
to the original data so that it's still
useful but which is random enough to
give the privacy guarantee
and this suggests kind of a promising
approach which is that we could try to
sample from a distribution
that is peaked around the input
and this leads to our first concrete
motivating example which is the problem
of differentially private low rank
approximation
so
in this problem you are given an n by n
complex positive
positive semi-definite matrix and you
want to output a rank k approximation to
y to the input matrix
so
specifically what we mean in this case
is you want to output a matrix p which
is a rank k projection so script p sub k
is a set of rank k projection matrices
such that the inner product of y with p
is maximized so these angle brackets
here and for the rest of the talk will
just indicate the hilbert schmidt or for
benious inner product of matrices we
just think of each matrix as a point in
euclidean space where the real and
complex part of each entry are
orthonormal coordinates and we take the
ordinary inner product
uh intuitively a way that you can think
about this is that the subspace that p
projects onto
kind of captures most of the information
about how y acts that is if we project
onto that subspace apply y and then
project again we should get an operator
that is uh as close to y as possible
now there's an easy way that we could do
this
that you might already have thought of
that is we can just plug y into an
eigensolver
find the eigenvalues or the the
eigenvectors that are associated to its
top k eigenvalues and project onto their
linear span uh the problem for this
application
is that then the output will be
deterministic and we want to solve the
problem in a differentially private way
so there are real applications where
being able to do differentially private
low-rank approximation is important so
in the context of the netflix challenge
this matrix might be say a covariance
matrix of user preferences and in that
context the low rank approximation
serves as a kind of noise reduction
it can help to filter out spurious
correlations
now there's a general approach to
differential privacy which is based on
the sampling idea from the previous
slide and this is called the exponential
mechanism
uh in this context
what we know is that in order to achieve
epsilon differential privacy it is
sufficient to efficiently sample the
output matrix from a probability measure
with a density with respect to the
uniform measure on
rank k projections that is given by e
raised to the power of epsilon times the
inner product of y
with p as you can see this distribution
is exponentially peaked around the
matrix that maximizes this linear
function
um
but
prior to the results that i'm going to
present in this talk
it wasn't known that an efficient
sampling algorithm actually existed as
far as we know the only results were in
the rank one case due to caprilav and
talwar
as another motivating example which also
makes a connection to the previous talk
by jonathan
we can consider the problem the the
following problem which is related to
quantum information
so this setup will be familiar to those
of you who saw the previous talk but
i'll recap
um
a state of a quantum mechanical system
can be represented by what's called a
density matrix which is just a positive
semi-definite matrix of trace one
the set of all n by n density matrices
is the convex hull of the set of all
rank one projections that is density
matrices with rank one which in the
context of quantum information are often
referred to as pure states
so given a density a matrix a
we would like to have a canonical way to
represent it as a convex combination of
pure states
what this means mathematically is that
we would like to have some probability
measure uh on the set of all pure states
whose expectation is equal to e uh to to
a which is in some sense canonical and
there is a well established way to do
this uh via the principle of maximum
entropy so we choose the distribution
over the pure states that has the
largest entropy among all distributions
with expectation a
now uh as jonathan discussed
here we're in a continuous setting we
have to be a little bit careful about
what we mean by largest entropy here
what we really mean by largest entropy
is the smallest callback liable
divergence from the uniform distribution
on the space of pure states and this
minimum value of the callback libel
divergence is called the barycentric
quantum entropy and it's an important
measure of entanglement so it tells us
in some sense how entangled the state a
is
now
the fact that you can actually compute
these maximum entropy distributions is
something that jonathan talked about in
the previous talk uh the maximum entropy
distribution satisfies a convex
optimization problem uh but it's a
problem in an infinite dimensional space
the space of all probability measures on
this manifold m
of uh probability measures or sorry of
uh of probability measures on on m
uh so here's that problem we're trying
to minimize the callback library
divergence here nu
is the density of the measure that we're
trying to find mu is the uniform measure
on m this first first constraint just
tells us that the expectation of the
density that we're looking for has to be
equal to a
the second constraint tells us that this
doesn't need to be the density of a
probability measure it needs to be
non-negative and integration
uh so this is an infinite dimensional
problem but
we have strong duality which lets us
reduce to a finite dimensional dual
convex program
and it turns out that the maximum
entropy distributions have the form e to
the power of inner product of y star
with x for
some
optimal y star
uh
so the conviction i showed that y star
can be efficiently computed
but they also raise the question of
whether one can actually sample from the
resulting distribution and the results
of this talk will answer that question
in the affirmative
so
both of these motivating examples
are actually special cases of the same
problem
to see this
first observe that in each case the
manifold that we're sampling from
has some symmetry it's invariant under
conjugation by unitary matrices that is
if we take a rank 1 or rank k projection
and we conjugate by some unitary we get
another rank 1 or rank k projection
um in fact
these are these these manifolds are both
exactly equal to the conjugation orbits
of specific hermitian matrices uh
under
uh the action of the unitary group
so more generally
for any n by n hermitian matrix lambda
we can define its unitary orbit o lambda
to be precisely the set of matrices that
are
generated by conjugating lambda by all
unitaries
and this is exactly the set of
permission matrices that have the same
eigenvalues as lambda
on such an orbit there is a unique
probability measure that is invariant
under this conjugation action which
we'll call mu lambda and this is
obtained just by starting with a hard
probability measure on un and pushing
forward by the map that sends u a
unitary matrix to u lambda u star
um
so with this setup both of the examples
we've discussed so far are then special
cases of
the following problem given two n by n
hermesian matrices lambda and y we would
like to efficiently sample from the
probability measure uh with density with
respect to mu lambda proportional to e
to the y inner product with x
so
it turns out that distributions of this
type are
extremely important in physics and
around a matrix theory where they appear
in a superficially different form and in
particular there is a famous formula
that jonathan also mentioned called the
hciz formula
which
gives an exact expression for the
partition function or really the
integral
of the distribution with density e to
the trace y u lambda u star with respect
to harm measure on the unitary group
so i'll say more about the hcis formula
in a bit but for now the key observation
is that if we send
u
to the matrix u lambda u star then this
hci z distribution on the unitary group
pushes forward to exactly the
distribution that we want to sample from
on the orbit so
there are kind of two sampling problems
that are equivalent we can either solve
this original sampling problem on the
orbit or we can just sample a matrix u
from this density on the unitary group
conjugate lambda by that
and then
output u lambda
so the general problem we want to solve
then is uh given y and lambda can we
officially sample from either of these
hci z distributions or from exponential
distributions on these unitary orbits
and
the fact that we can do this is the main
result of this talk
so specifically given some c greater
than zero
uh we provide two different algorithms
that sample approximately from the
desired distribution on the orbits with
error
c uh
again as far as we only as as far as we
know the only existing work on this was
in the rank one real case uh due to
capital after talwar what i mean here by
the rank one real case is that they only
considered the the the orbit of uh uh
this diagonal matrix with with one
followed by a bunch of zeros which gives
rank one projections but they consider
its orbit under the action of the real
orthogonal group rather than the complex
unitary group
so i said that we'll give two algorithms
the differences between the two
algorithms uh are are in two points one
is the the sense
in which we achieve this error c
and the other is the running time
so the first version of the algorithm
uh
approximates the measure that we want to
sample from in a total variation
distance and the number of operations is
polynomial in log one over the error
the second version of the algorithm
approximates nu with error in infinity
divergence but the number of operations
is polynomial in one over c
one over the error
rather than a log one over here so uh
here are the definitions of those two
senses of the error just for those who
aren't familiar the salient point is
that the infinity divergence is an upper
bound on the total variation distance so
the second algorithm gives a tighter
error bound however the trade-off is
that the asymptotic run time is longer
we'll leave it as an open problem
to
determine whether you can in fact sample
with infinity divergence error with uh
um runtime polynomial and log one over
here if you could do that that would
subsume both of these theorems and we
could only have a a single theorem uh
instead of two
is that what the
does the capital of all work get that
run time
uh capital of tower gets uh log one over
c but um
but uh only gets an error mounted total
variation okay
so these algorithms have applications to
a number of problems that arise as
special cases of sampling from hcic
distributions uh including both of the
motivating examples that i discussed so
sampling from
max entropy distributions and unitary
orbits
and also epsilon differentially private
low rank approximation in complex vector
spaces as well as sampling from complex
matrix orange bound distributions that
arise in directional statistics
now most of the rest of this talk is
going to be devoted to describing our
sampling algorithms and sketching the
proof of the main result but before that
as promised i want to say a bit more
about the hciz formula
so this is an exact formula
that gives the integral of the function
e to the trace y u lambda u star with
respect to the normalized harm measure
on the unitary group so here big y and
big lambda are two hermitian matrices
and the little ys and lambdas on the
right hand side are the respective
eigenvalues
uh
so
in in in this formula as written on the
slide we have assumed that uh
the the ys and lambdas are all distinct
uh obviously otherwise the denominator
vanishes but it's not too hard to see
that in situations where y or lambda
have coinciding eigenvalues the
numerator vanishes to the same degree
and you can get another exact formula
just by applying l'hopital's rule to
this expression
so
we can think of this formula as giving
the partition function for the hci z
distribution on u n that is just the the
normalizing constant that makes the hci
z distribution into a probability
measure
but this integral is absolutely
ubiquitous in a bunch of other settings
in contemporary math and physics
so it was originally shown by haris
chandra in the 50s in the context of
harmonic analysis on leigh algebras it
was then independently rediscovered by
its extended zubair two physicists
in the late 70s early 80s in the context
of gage theory
but it shows up all over the place
um
so just to to sort of list a smattering
of examples and random matrix theory uh
it appears in expressions for the joint
spectral densities of wishart matrices
which model sample covariance matrices
uh correlated gaussian matrices and
several other important random matrix
models
um in quantum field theory uh as i
already mentioned it shows up in models
of the strong nuclear force those are
the gauge theories i talked about
but in a simplified setting where
space-time is discrete in representation
theory you can use integrals of this
form uh to write down the irreducible
characters of the general linear groups
and symbolic geometry you can interpret
this as a laplace transform of a dostrom
hacking measure associated to a taurus
action on a flag manifold uh it also
arises in combinatorics in the study of
lozenge tilings it has an interpretation
and enumerative geometry as a generating
function for uh the monotone double
herbert's numbers which count
a
certain family of riemann surfaces
and because of the connection with which
are matrices uh this formula is also
used a bunch in high dimensional
statistics and in signal processing so
in in statistics um
uh which art matrices are used to model
noise uh in sample covariance estimators
particularly for large data sets um
and in signal processing it turns out
the complex wishart matrices uh control
the channel capacity for multiple input
multiple output antenna systems this is
used for um
for performance analysis for antenna
arrays and there are plenty of other
examples now the point of telling you
all this uh aside from the fact that i
think is interesting is just to point
out that given the ubiquity of the
partition function for this distribution
and the wide range of situations in
which one needs to be able to calculate
it
uh it's kind of surprising that we only
now have an algorithm for sampling from
the distribution itself
also the fact that
uh
this this at first somewhat funny
looking function turns out to be a very
common object uh is
we hope an indication that the sampling
algorithms as well may continue to find
uh applications that we haven't thought
of yet
so
user representation theory okay and in
the context of representation theory um
this integral shows up in
the
i mean
essentially this is the integral that
shows up in the cure love character
formula uh for for
the unit
uh or or more generally for the general
number so there's this whole
uh a program and representation theory
called the kerala orbit method and this
is kind of the the the central uh
formula uh in that um i mean it's it's
it's kind of a long story but if if
you're interested in applications or
representation theory uh
loss book lectures on the orbit method
is a really realistic start
i think uh
like
would those applications
need algorithms like what are the other
questions
uh
in representation theory uh i don't know
uh yeah we have not worked on
applications to representation theory
specifically uh but i would be happy to
talk about it afterwards if that
and
so
to sort of start sketching how the
algorithm actually works
um
the
algorithm exploits the symmetries of the
unitary orbits and of the hcis entity
itself
and to do so it relies on a kind of
inductive or self-reducible structure in
the problem
but
not quite in the usual sense of
self-reducibility so usually what we
mean
when we say that some computational
problem is self-reducible
is that an instance of the problem of a
given input size can be efficiently
reduced to an instance of the same
problem with a smaller input size so if
given a problem instance of size n if i
can reduce in polynomial time to a
instance of the same problem with size n
minus one then obviously i can solve the
entire problem in polynomial time
often the key to making this kind of
approach work is an efficient algorithm
for computing some relevant partition
function
uh so here is a a
a simple example
uh to illustrate this so consider the
case of uniformly sampling a uh
a perfect matching of a graph
so a perfect matching
is a list of edges in a graph
such that
uh
each verse such that each vertex
in the graph has exactly one edge in
that list that is incident on it
so another way of thinking of this is
you are just pairing off
vertices in the graph each vertex can
only be paired with one other vertex
but you can only pair vertices that are
connected by an edge
so
if i want to uniformly sample
from the set of all possible matchings
of a given graph i can do so as follows
i start off by choosing just any edge e
in the graph
i then use my partition function oracle
so in this case the partition function
that i want to be able to compute
is just the function that given any
graph tells me the total number of
matchings of that graph that exists
so i use that oracle
first to compute the number p of
matchings uh that contain e
so uh the number p of matchings that
contain e is just the number of total
matchings of the graph that i would get
by removing e and the two vertices that
it joins
right and then i also compute the total
number of matchings of the graph that
may or may not contain
uh so then i flip a biased coin
and i include e in my final matching
with probability equal to p over q
in the next step i construct a smaller
graph
uh and i do that as follows if
i
did not choose to include e in my
matching then i just remove that edge
if i did choose to include to include e
in my matching then i remove the edge
and i also remove the two vertices
joined
by e and
all of the edges incident on them
and then i just apply the same algorithm
to this smaller graph
adding one edge to my list at a time and
when no vertices are left i know that
i've finished and i just output that
list of
of edges i know that it will be a
uniformly sampled perfect match
so
in the problem that we're studying here
we're in a continuous setting
and we do have a formula for the
partition function that's just the hci z
integral that i showed you on the
previous slide
but it's not actually clear how this
helps and the reason that it's not clear
how this helps is that it's not obvious
how to reduce the problem size
uh
so
there are a couple of uh ways that you
could think of to
to try to reduce the size of the problem
right like you could potentially try to
sample your matrix you know one one
entry at a time or one row at a time
uh
the issue is that it's not clear that
this actually gives you an instance of
the same problem right sampling the
first m rows
of a unitary matrix is operatory quite
different from sampling an n by n
unitary matrix
moreover
there are correlations between
the rows in between the entries
we need the output to lie in a fixed
unitary orbit and
those unitary orbits are cut out by a
big list of algebraic constraints right
like the entries and the matrices have
to satisfy a bunch of polynomials that
come from the fact that they have to
have the form u lambda u star for some
unitary u
uh
so
as i if if if you try to sample row by
row or entry by entry
there you you sort of build up a bunch
of dependencies as you go
um and the constraints start to change
and it's not really clear that you know
after you sample an entry you're going
to have uh an instance of the same
problem that you started with
so
instead of taking an approach like this
uh what we do
is to take advantage of a natural
self-reducible structure in the geometry
of the unitary orbits and that's going
to be the starting point for the
overview
of the proof
so to recall our goal here
we're given hermitian uh hermitian
matrices y and lambda and we want to
sample from the
distribution with density proportional
to e to the inner product of y
uh
with x uh d mu lambda of x
all right so first let's look at the
simplest case
where y equals zero
in that situation
this distribution just is mu lambda
right it's just the uniform distribution
on the orbit
what that means
is that in order to uh to sample x we
can just sample a random unitary uh
conjugate it
conjugate lambda by it and output that
so in this situation we've reduced the
problem to sampling a heart unitary
which you can do as follows
we know that the eigenvectors
of a unitary matrix
are
are uniformly distributed on the unit
sphere uh in cn conditional on the fact
that they have to be orthonormal
so we start by just sampling uh any
standard gaussian n-dimensional complex
vector we normalize it so that it lies
on the unit sphere then we restrict to
the subspace that's orthogonal to that
vector and repeat
until we have a list of n vectors and
those are just the columns of our matrix
that's a hard unit term
then we conjugate lambda by that and
that's the matrix that we wanted
unfortunately uh
this kind of simple approach does not
work for any other value of y
the issue is that
uh this density on the orbit uh or the
exponential density on the unitary group
uh stops being unitarily invariant it's
no longer a constant density um as soon
as you have y non-zero
um
so we don't have this kind of like
conditional independence between the
columns of the unitary that we want um
uh we sort of run into the same issue
that i talked about on uh
the the previous slide
where the columns are correlated
so
we need some other approach
so instead of thinking about like
columns or entries the idea is instead
to view matrices in terms of their
eigenvalues
now you might object that all matrices
in the orbit o lambda have the same
eigenvalues and that's true but we're
not going to think just about the
eigenvalues of the full matrix we're
going to think in terms of the
eigenvalues of all of the leading
submatrices so
that is we're going to look at
all of the k by k
matrices that lie in the upper left
corner
of the matrix
that we're trying to sample
for k
from 1 to n
and it turns out
that
if you know the eigenvalues of all of
the leading sub-matrices of some
hermitian matrix x
these
almost fully determine the matrix x that
is they determine its eigenval its its
eigenvectors as well up to a complex
phase of the entry so you sort of know
the absolute values of the coordinates
of all the eigenvectors
i didn't understand
oh by leading i just mean like they lie
in the top left corner
but shouldn't there be one k by three
matrix on the top of the corner oh yeah
but values okay uh it looks like this
right yeah so we so we're looking at all
the corners
um so the first one second one the third
one
um
does that make sense so
there is a a well-studied map
that maps a hermitian matrix to
the collection of eigenvalues of all of
its k by k principle miners or leading
sub matrices this is called the railing
map
and we think of
a point in the image of the rayleigh map
as a collection of lists of eigenvalues
which are in each row in descending
order and we'll kind of arrange them in
a triangle like this so here r one one
is just the uh the the top
left corner entry uh
r one two and r two two are the
eigenvalues of this two by two block
considered as a matrix by itself and
then the bottom row this is a three by
three matrix is just fixed equal to the
eigenvalues lambda that we started with
all right so to get a better feeling for
the rayleigh map uh let's consider the
case of rank one projections um so in
this situation the matrix lambda that
we're starting with is just this matrix
e one the diagonal matrix whose diagonal
consists of a one followed by zeros
um
the unitary orbit of this matrix is the
space of all rank 1 projection matrices
um which geometrically is just a complex
projected space
uh so in this situation
uh
the um
the rayleigh map uh is is is fairly
simple of actually going to map the
orbit to the standard simplex as
jonathan talked about uh in his talk
so to see this note that uh at most one
eigenvalue of each leading sub matrix of
a rank one projection can be nonzero
right if x is rank one
then all of its uh leading submatrices
have to be ranked at most one
um
we also have the koshi interlacing
theorem which says that the eigenvalues
of the n minus one by n minus one
leading submatrix interlace the
eigenvalues of the uh the the full
matrix and this gives us the sequence of
inequalities that relate the largest
eigenvalues
of each leading sub-matrix
so
we have
only
n
coordinates
um
in this point in the image of the
rayleigh map it can be nonzero
and we have a a
simple linear transformation that maps
these uh the
these coordinates to the standard
simplex that is if you consider all
these differences uh which uh if you
just think about the traces
of the leading sub-matrices these are
just equal to the entries in the
diagonal of the matrix these all have to
add up to one
so the diagonal of the matrix gives a
point in the standard simplex which
encodes
the leading eigenvalues of
of all of these sub matrices
so we see in this case is that the
railing map projects a non-convex
manifold onto a convex polytope
um but what about the general case
of more general unitary orbits
what we'll find is that the rayleigh map
always maps the orbit to a convex
polytope and also that the exponential
density transforms nicely under this
projection
so to see how this works uh
uh
again we'll call the cauchy interlacing
theorem the
eigenvalues of each of these blocks
has to in
have to interlace the eigenvalues
of the next largest block that contains
it
so this is why we write down these
coordinates r
uh in in a triangle we have this
triangular
set of inequalities that relate them
called the interlacing inequalities
if we fix the bottom row of this
triangle to be equal to lambda
we
have one half n times n minus one
remaining entries in the triangle that
they can take other values
uh if we think about these as points in
uh one half n times n minus one
dimensional vector space then these
inequalities cut out a convex polytope
which is called the gelfont polytope of
lambda
and what
the
interlacing theorem says is that
the rayleigh map maps the orbit into
this polygon but it turns out that we
can say more than that
the rayleigh map maps the orbit onto the
polytope as well and moreover
the uniform measure on the orbit under
this mapping projects to the uniform
measure on the polytope
so
if i give you a uniform random hermitian
matrix with fixed eigenvalues
you know nothing
about the uh the the eigenvalues of the
leading submatrices except that the
interlinks essentially the analyzing
theorem tells you everything that you
know about the
the the eigenvalues of the leading
sub-matrices of a
uniform random permission matrix with
fixed eigenvalues
moreover
this exponential density
on the orbit also maps to an exponential
density on the alpha telepolito because
uh it
um one can show that it's constant on
the fibers of the rayleigh map that is
the the pre-images of any given point
all have the same value of this
exponential function
why is diagonal here
uh
yes y is diagonal although
uh
it doesn't
part
yes why is that
we can we can essentially assume without
generation
without loss of generality of the y
but then you should pick the relative
phenomena
um
well in this situation we're just
thinking about the eigenvalues of
what's the
i guess maybe
like is it is it true that whatever the
eigen basis of y is that's the basis in
which you have to like choose these
minors um
[Music]
oh um
no we're we're okay so you know we're
we're
we're thinking okay think of these
matrices as operators on some vectors on
on some euclidean space uh
or you know some
complex permission space we pick an
orthonormal basis to begin with and that
fixes the matrix entrance
so we can really identify each matrix
with just a grid of numbers
and we're looking at
the the the rectangle in the corner
so yeah this is fact about
the fibers have constant density that
doesn't matter on
what basis y is diagonal
but yeah i mean yeah it's fair you
you've said it's diagonals yeah it it
you know i think i think
i think you're right we might have to uh
yeah but if we don't take y to be
diagonal to begin with uh we can always
diagonalize y and then kind of undo it
later just by you know conjugating the
result that we get by something else
um so we can always reduce to the case
where y is diagonal so that we do have
some of these constants yeah
yeah right you know the the
the point is that you know when
when
you
expand out
this inner product you want to get
something that only depends on the
diagonal entries of y and the diagonal
entries of x and then by taking the
differences of the traces you can write
the diagonal
entries in x uh in terms of things that
you know just from this polynomial
because it only depends on the
eigenvalues of the the system
but yeah i think that for that you do
want you do on yba
um
but again it's it's it's not a a
difficult assumption to uh to to remove
all right so
because our density behaves nicely under
this projection uh this suggests an
algorithm
that is um
we're going to perform two steps in the
first step we're going to sample a point
r
from the exponential density uh that we
end up with after we take this push
forward to the galfond telepo
golf on settling polytope we're now
sampling from a convex set so
we can use
techniques that that work in a convex
setting
and then uh we will transfer the sample
from the polytope to a sample from the
orbit
the fact that this density is a
constant on the fibers means that after
we sample a point in the polytope um in
order to transfer that to the orbit we
just need to sample uniformly from the
fiber over that point
so
the first step uh uses some pre-existing
general algorithms for sampling from log
concave densities on a convex polygon
the push forward density to the polytope
uh is still exponential so
it is log linear and therefore log
concave we have very powerful general
methods for sampling from log concave
densities on complex polytopes
um
to sample with error in total variation
distance we use a method due to lavash
and valpala
which runs in time polynomial in log one
over the error
for the infinity divergence error we use
a different algorithm due to bassline
smith and decorator which runs in time
polynomial and one over the error both
of these algorithms are
used use markov chain methods
the
total variation distance algorithm uses
a hit and run walk the infinity
divergence algorithm uses a modified
grid walk the reason that you get
different error bounds and different
running times this relates to the
convergence rate of these two markov
chains and the sense in which they
converge to their stationary
distributions
so for step two we have to do some
additional work
in this step we want to convert our
sample from the polytope into a sample
from the orbit
now as noted before given the sample
from the orbit the desired output is
uniformly distributed on the fiber over
that point
so we need to describe the fiber first
of all and then we need a way to
construct a uniform sample from it
now our approach
is going to be to build up a matrix in
the fiber one leading submatrix at a
time
so we'll start with the entry
in the top left corner which is just
equal to r11
and then
we will inductively sample a new row and
column
at each step
so in each step of the algorithm we are
given the k by k
leading sub matrix x k
we know its eigenvalues
and we want to sample a new matrix x k
plus 1
with eigenvalues given by the k plus 1th
row in the triangle that we sampled
which we can write in this form with
some entry c on the diagonal and then
this vector v
and v star off of the diagonal
so it turns out that at each step this
diagonal entry c is deterministic it's
completely determined uh by algebraic
constraints since you can write it in
terms of
the the entries in the rayleigh triangle
that we already know
and the vector v
is uniformly distributed on a product of
spheres
in some complex vector space
so to illustrate why we should sample
the uniformly formed product of spheres
i'll just show you the simplest case
which is where this matrix xk is
diagonal
and has distinct eigenvalues for the
situation where xk is not diagonal it's
pretty easy to generalize you just have
to conjugate everything by some
appropriate unitary matrix
so
uh first note the this point r in the
golf and telling polytope that we
already sampled determines the
eigenvalues of both xk and xk plus one
the idea is that we'll write down the
characteristic polynomial of x k plus
one in two different ways first uh just
writing it in terms of the eigenvalues
and second by expanding along this last
row and column uh of the form of x k
plus one that we've written over here
we'll then set these two expressions
equal to each other
and solve for the modulus squared of the
jth coordinate of v
and what we get when we do that is this
expression
so this determines the vector v up to
complex phases of the entry
all the remains is to uniformly sample
each coordinate v j from the complex
circle with radius given by the right
hand side of this expression
now first of all you might object this
is supposed to be the modulus squared uh
of some number how do i know that this
ratio of products is uh actually
non-negative well uh if you look at it
for a little bit it turns out that the
the non-negativity of this expression is
guaranteed by the interlacing
inequalities
in the situation where xk does not have
distinct eigenvalues the denominator
of this expression is going to vanish
in that situation
you can still take the same approach of
writing the characteristic polynomial
two different ways and setting them
equal to each other just when you solve
for the vjs in that situation you'll end
up with a slightly more complicated
expression and in particular on the left
hand side rather than having just a
single vj you will have uh some
a a sum
of uh some number of vjs squared equal
to the multiplicity of that eigenvalue
so in that situation you sample those
coordinates of the vector v
from
a higher dimensional complex sphere
rather than just from a circle so that's
why
the the the fiber ends up having uh the
the form of a product of spheres
as a final note
this fiber sampling algorithm is
approximation preserving so the error
bounds that we got after sampling on
the polytope transfer without uh without
modification to the sample to to to the
sample from the fiber into our final
output
all right
so to wrap up
the main results in this talk were a
couple of efficient sampling algorithms
for approximate sampling from
hcic distributions or from exponential
distributions on unitary orbits of
formation matrices
i talked about a couple of applications
to physics
as well as maximum energy distributions
and to differential privacy there are
also applications to statistics and
possibly beyond
to finish i want to mention a couple of
open problems so one i already talked
about which is whether we can improve
the one over c dependence to a log one
over c dependence in the run time for
the algorithm that samples uh with error
in infinity divergence if we were able
to do that we would only need one
theorem it would subsume both of the
results that i presented here
a second open problem
is whether similar techniques can be
used to sample from orbits of the
orthogonal group
in general
rather than only orbits from the unitary
group
uh
that
certain parts
of the approach that uh i showed in this
talk do work in that setting other parts
do not we still have a push forward to
uh to the golf on settling polytope uh
the eigenvalues of a real symmetric
matrix do still interlace
the issue is that the in that case the
uniform measure on the orbit no longer
pushes forward to the uniform measure on
the polytope and in fact in general it
pushes forward to something that is not
log concave so um these markov chain
methods that we use to sample from the
polytope uh really require log concavity
um
in the orthogonal setting that log
concavity breaks down and uh we we need
something else
um
finally if there's one taken from this
talk it's just kind of one of the the
main themes of this whole workshop which
is that continuous symmetries uh can be
useful for designing optimization and
sampling algorithms on manifolds
particularly for overcoming issues of
non-convexity
thank you very much
are there any questions
questions
uh questions from online
angle
ah
nice okay i have a few questions
is it working now yes
um
so the first question is
what does your algorithm tell about
sampling semi-standard young tableau
if you know the connection
or or in integer points in this gulf
unsettling polytope
right so
um
you know i thought about this a little
bit when we were first working on
this problem and i i remember thinking
that there should be an application and
then starting to doubt it so let me see
if i can uh okay so you know one
right so you know what one thing that
you could do
is
you could try to
and i i
i guess if you just want to sample a
uniform
random semi-standard young tableau you
could probably
use
something like this
at least in
the the case of um of the infinity
divergence result maybe you could just
do some kind of like grid walk on
integer points in the polytope um
well i'm i'm not completely certain
about what i'm about to say i think we
concluded that
if you want to sample from like an
exponential density
on
uh
on
semi-standard young tableau it's no
longer clear
that if you just do something like
sampling a point from the polytope and
then rounding
that you actually still end up sampling
from something that's a good
approximation of the distribution that
you wanted to start with but i wouldn't
be able to tell you more
specific technical details than that
okay i say thanks well the other
questions were
would depend on your answer but yeah i
mean let's talk about it afterwards
particularly if you have ideas for some
applications
okay uh there's no other questions we
can thank call again
and uh